Talk of the morning as Marco carmassino
talking about learning again
yep more learning now thank you everyone
for for having me for this so this is
Joint work with um Eric Benedict who's
at UCSD uh Russell's PhD student now I'm
Marco carmisino I'm at IBM uh this is
Auntie Nicole colova at mon Rami Ramya
at nmt and Manuel Sabin who was
affiliated with UC UC Berkeley when when
this work was done okay so learning with
distributional inverters uh what is that
what am I talking about today this is
just one weird trick that is going to
reduce learning
um in a variety of settings over
efficiently sampleable distributions to
learning over just the uniform
distribution and we'll we'll give a
concrete application of that and a
generic application of that in this talk
and it is it is literally a three-step
reduction that works in a bunch of
places so I just want to show it to you
on the Whiteboard and that's our plan
for today
okay as usual the motivation is to
advance learning of simple concept
classes where simple means that we can
prove complexity lower bounds against
those against those classes without
working too hard and today that'll mean
the natural proofs barrier barrier or
the existence of distinguishers for
pseudorandom functions in that class but
the specifics of this are not going to
come up at all
what did come up already
um in this Workshop thank you Haley for
letting me reproduce this slide is a a
reference to the generic version of this
work where we go from natural properties
to pack pack learning over any fixed
polynomally sample distribution that's
us uh with membership queries
and again to elaborate on our plan and
explicitness today this is uh thank you
again Haley for uh letting me take a
look at these slides
um they get from the stronger assumption
that mktp on the uniform distribution is
an average BPP they get uh white box
access to the distribution and they get
random examples which is amazing this as
far as I understand it's a huge open
problem to do this with just mcsp or
just a natural property
um we just have a natural property
um we do get fixed distribution learning
and I will be very explicit about this
notion of white box access that we need
for the sampler
um show where it comes from and it's
part of this reduction
okay
so that's the setup that's another place
where it shows up and let me be more
concrete about our results
so first we start with the concretely
specifying the concrete results we can
query learn ac0 mod P that's um
I'll Define the circus class later but
constant death circuits with counting on
P Gates over concise product
distributions so uh what is that we get
query access to a function in the Target
concept class we get randomized
quasi-polynomial time and we get this
explicit list of biases of the product
distribution Pi so that means that you
have uh n Bits each bit has probability
P sub I of being one independently you
sample each bit in sequence
um that is the type of distribution that
that we can learn over where previous
work only learned over the uniform
distribution so this is this is like
some small departure from the uniform
distribution but it is progress
um yeah and we output a circuit H
approximating that function when fresh
inputs or challenges are sampled from
the product distribution that you told
my algorithm about in advance by sending
over these biases
okay now we have some conditional
results if there are natural proofs of
circuit lower bounds
then we can query learn Boolean circuits
over
polytime sampleable distributions where
we'll depend on the code of that
distribution in a way that I will be
super explicit about when we come to
that part of the talk given so given
query access to the function randomized
polynomial time and the code of a
polytime sampler for the example
distribution we can print a circuit
approximating F over that distribution
so when examples are sampled fresh from
mu we get exactly this condition over
here okay
so those are the results here's our plan
we're going to do
um
just quick statements of Prior work on
learning circuits in this setting uh
both concrete and conditional we're
going to sketch our algorithms and we're
going to conclude with some open
problems that I think are exciting
especially you know here because
conditional constructions of better
cryptographic Primitives will let us
expand the scope of distributions that
that we could learn over and make the
conditional results better too and I
hope that it's Crystal Clear once the
talk is over
how and where those open problems plug
into these pieces on the Whiteboard okay
so I'm I don't even need to going you
know on the last day of this Workshop
um right before lunch I don't need to
tell you what this circuit is right it's
it's a dag we have and or not Gates and
it's it's the worst thing in the world
because we don't know anything about
them
um
so the the key idea in this work is
again has shown up all over this
Workshop we're going to exploit the um
sometimes implicit sometimes explicit
constructivity of proofs from complexity
Theory and cryptography and chain those
together into learning algorithms
okay so circuit classes and lower bounds
again very quickly here's ac0
it has and or not Gates
um we restricted to polynomial size
constant depth Unbound and fan in
um the lower bound is parity
so what's the next thing you do you add
parity to your gate set and you get the
um
next circuit class ac0 mod P or mod 2
and for Q and p district distinct primes
we have that the mod Q function doesn't
have
um ac0 mod P circuits that's the classic
result of rasborough smilensky and a
natural property can be extracted from
that
foreign
so let's put the uh let's put the
learning algorithm side by side for
these classes LMN
um 1989 given sample access to a
function in ac0 and randomized quasi
polynomial time they can output a good
approximating circuit over the uniform
distribution how do they get this
um they use a Fourier decomposition or
bounds on the Fourier spectrum of any
function in ac0 that importantly they
extracted that decomposition in those
properties by hand from the circuit
lower bounds against ac0.
um in my previous work with antonina
Valentin and Russell hello
um we given query access to any function
in ac0 mod P and randomized posi
polynomial time
we can output the same kind of uh
approximator and we use
natural properties the natural
properties from the previous slide
circuit lower bounds here to somewhat
generically
um construct this learning algorithm out
of a variety of distinguished or
distinguisher to predictor
um
constructions
and yeah I just want to emphasize that
these match almost everywhere except for
the query versus sample access and the
um specific hand-tuned learning
algorithm versus okay we drop the
natural proof into this construction and
we get it
good
okay so let's let's take the next step
the uniform distribution is not the only
distribution in the world or so I've
been told by people who actually do
learning
um
fsj-91 they were able to learn ac0 over
over product distributions so same
access conditions
um and then they also get a list of the
biases so this is uh this is that kind
of fixed distribution learning setting
and they're able to Output a circuit
that approximates the target concept
well over this product distribution that
you're given explicitly great now how
did they do it they actually gave two
different algorithms for this in the
paper and they're both quite nice the
first one is a kind of a generalized
foray analysis of LMN where they they
switch up the basis of the that the that
the algorithm like finds heavy Fourier
coefficient Fourier coefficients in to
to account for the biases in the product
distribution that's very cool
um and then they also they reduce they
again they go in by hand and they reduce
lnn over this specific product
distribution to LMN over uniform
okay
so in this work what do we do we learn
ac0 mod P over product distributions
concretely given
um exactly the same kind of access
except the queries which we can't get
rid of
um we output the same style of
approximator circuit and the algorithm
there's no way this is going to work
right so we're we're of course inspired
by um
fjs 91 this is what we start with but
the the previous algorithm cikk has
nothing whatsoever to do with the
Fourier spectrum of the functions indeed
it can't because these classes they have
parity right in them of unbounded Fannin
so this is a non-starter so what we do
instead is we generalize exactly this
um instead of reducing LMN specifically
over a product distribution to LMN over
the uniform distribution we reduce
learning over product distributions to
learning over the over the uniform
distribution okay
so uh let me sketch this
really quickly and it's nice because
it's simple
uh first I'm gonna tell you what a
sampler is so mu is going to be a
distribution on end bit strings
and we're going to have an efficient
procedure that takes our bits of input
the coins for the sampler and the
samples it samples from you if for every
uh Target string in the range the
probability distribution given giving
the sampler like true random coins is
exactly the mass of X under that
distribution so S Sub mu is going to map
uh random coins to Strings distributed
exactly according to x
uh the the class of these that you can
do efficiently is called it's called
piecing
um
so and given given this definition we
can imagine a very natural definition of
a sampler for a product distribution
right just write down write down the
coefficients and Sample uh
proportionally with with rejection
sampling it's very efficient okay so
here's the pseudo code for learning
let's suppose that we've got some Target
function inside an example Oracle F and
it's also inside a concept class that we
can learn Lambda
uh over the uniform distribution already
now let's say I'm going to be uh very
Cavalier about this for now and then
very specific let's say we have some I
sub mu and inverter for the sampler so
if I does this have a
yeah so if I get
something from the range of the sampler
I can get something from
the domain of the sampler I can turn
samples into coins it's an inverter for
that S Sub mu and yeah and I have that
lambdas learnable over the uniform
distribution and finally I have one of
these composition properties right so if
I take
the sampler from you and I compose it
with my target concept I can name that
that's a new function uh G of Z note
that this this now goes from
uh sampler coins
to to decisions not from examples to
decisions and let me have G inside my
target concept class okay so if if um
so in particular if the sampler was
already inside Lambda and Lambda is
closed under compositions I can I can
have this
uh what are we gonna do we're we're
going to use the inverter to recover our
coins and call our learning algorithm
over the uniform distribution so step
one
um we're gonna learn G over the uniform
Distribution on R bits which is
appropriate coins for the sampler and
now let me start being explicit about
stuff like where do I need code uh over
here
I need the sampler code to simulate G
right because I've got an F Oracle I
don't I don't have
um I don't have a g Oracle but if I've
got the code for the sampler I can just
say Okay learning algorithm whatever you
ask for I'm going to first uh
plug that into the sampler and then plug
that into a query to F so I can simulate
this no problem with an F Oracle and
then observe that my my challenge is
right my fresh inputs that I measure the
quality of my hypothesis with respect to
those are distributed by Lambda just
according to the setup of the learning
problem so at the end at the end of this
algorithm very simple I print my
hypothesis is the hypothesis that came
out of learning over the uniform
distribution with the inverter hidden
inside of it okay
and this is the second place where I'm
going to need uh the code of the sampler
because the construction of inverters
that we use has to print the code of the
sampler into the construction
so code of the sampler shows up and
exactly this this is this is what white
box means on Haley's slide it means that
I need the code of the sampler to
simulate these queries and I actually
need it to shove into this inverter over
here that will be output as part of as
part of my hypothesis
okay
um
choices for this I assume you like do
they matter does it matter yes
anything okay so you're you're jumping
ahead a tiny bit but yeah so are there
any questions besides what kind of I
submu do we have because I think at this
point the idea is like very clear and
straightforward
so
um if you're not shooting for proper
learning it's still important that SW
you be in the class
or at least the composition be in the
class
but isomu is just used is just used in
the output yes so you don't have to
actually have a new in the class yeah if
I'm that's a that's a very good question
so if I'm not shooting for proper
learning I submu can be any efficient
circuit
um because I'm allowing my hypothesis to
be as complex as it needs to be to do
the job so for example in our setting
um we need an nc2 circuit to execute the
natural property against ac0 mod P
anyway so this already has an nc2
natural property stuck inside of it so
additionally putting the inverter from
impalaso will be doesn't hurt too much
um yeah so this is where we need
efficiency we need if if we're not doing
proper alert we need the sampler to live
inside the target of concept class
okay so and then Ryan next next slide
we'll come to look at this this is doing
um an awful lot of work right this this
definition of a good inverter
um
so let's just let's unpack that and
apply it together to this problem
the conceptual message is that we picked
out a definition of good inverter from
classical cryptography such that this
this pseudo code quote just works and
the interesting thing about what um
fsj91 did is they had a different
definition of good inverter that that
wasn't quite as powerful as this one
they actually had like kind of a hand
tailored definition of good inverter
that was kind of um
very close to what LMN was doing was
doing anyway and it turns out that if
you just take this additional step of
abstraction their idea generalizes so
this is distributional Inversion from
impalaso Ruby 90 one-way functions are
essential for minicrypt so
um basically we get statistical
simulation of coin image pairs for those
samplers
uh
again really the the only technical
components here are either conditional
or unconditional constructions of
distributional inverters because we have
to get them from somewhere and we kind
of give this proof of concept for
reductions from learning sample bleed to
learning over the uniform distribution
and this this induces a few partial
answers to some questions that uh fjs91
had so one question was this very
natural is ac0 learnable over ac0 Sam
like that seems kind of reasonable right
and the answer well if there's no
distributional one-way functions in
there then yeah we can run our reduction
on lnn like we that's all you need to do
um and then the question they also asked
like when in general does inverter
learning work because they did have a
like specific definition kind of cooked
up for LMN and we can just say whenever
a mu sampler is
um distributionally invertible and fits
inside the target concept class so that
the original algorithm still works
the instance of what why do you think
that the ac0 does not have a
distribution of one oh I have no idea
about that that's one of my open
questions Actually I don't even know if
um nc0 should thank you
um that yeah we'll come to that at the
end where I talk about efficiency of
building
um cryptographic Primitives from other
cryptographic Primitives those are
obstacles for this approach to to work
in general and in specific cases so yeah
great question
um I have no idea I just know that
this is one way to answer this question
determine whether or not ac0 has
distribution one-way functions in it you
could
if it does does that imply a no answer
no
I think I think it does like I I think
that you can you can build a
distribution that's hard to learn over
inside ac0 stamp even though you can
learn over
ac0 uniform with Helen by existing so I
I think um yeah I think so but I'm not
completely sure
question
I will think carefully about that
okay
so
what exactly is a good inverter and how
to use it
um this is statistical and
distinguishability
I'm going to have two distributions mu
naught and U1 uh they're on m-bit
strings you're going to have some Delta
between zero and one then I say that
these two distributions are um
statistically indistinguishable within
distance Delta if for every T that's a
subset of 0 1 M bits
uh you can't you can't tell them apart
using this test the probability that a
string shows up in t under mu naught
versus mu 1 is is Delta close so what
this says is not even an information
theoretic adversary like an adversary
who knows this set T that may be very
difficult to construct can distinguish
these two distributions by looking at
them
um
so what you
can do is Define distributional
inversion of a sampler based on this
statistical distance notion so let I sub
mu be an efficient randomized TM and I'm
going to suppress dependencies on the
size of the examples that we're sampling
and the coins of IMU for legibility here
but this is this is the important part
of this definition of distributional
inversion what it says
where Z is sampled according to use of R
so first what does this mean this is
legitimate coins for the sampler
this distribution the circle is
concatenation is legitimate coins for
the sampler and the output of the
sampler so this is input output sampler
pairs
over here on the other side I've got a
legitimate sample from the sampler
and then over here I've got okay we ran
the sampler and then we wrapped it in
the inverter
so the inverter is remember is sending
um
n bit strings to our bit strings so this
will also type check right it'll look
like an orbit string and bitstring pair
and then this just says that these pairs
this distribution over pairs is
statistically indistinguishable
um
if you want to be very precise about the
difference between what we were doing in
fsj10 they had a condition that only
controlled um that didn't control pairs
but this is the right notion from
impalazo Luby for enforcing niceness of
the distribution of outputs of the
inverter
okay
and what are we actually going to do
with this our reduction is that we're
just going to substitute fake coin
sampler pairs from the inverter into the
correctness condition of learning over
the uniform distribution right
so our adversary in some sense is the
correctness guarantee of learning over
uniform
and now we're going to switch to being
on the Whiteboard for a little bit while
while I discuss that
okay
so step one over here is
I have to I have to define a statistical
test that corresponds to the correctness
of my learning over uniform algorithm to
to fool with this inverter
what's that going to be it's just going
to be
error sub H so that's the error fixing h
of Z compose X
is going to be the set sorry z concat x
of Z concat X's
such that
my hypothesis on Z
disagrees
with um
with my function
on X okay this is appropriately typed
it's got coins and then examples it's
it's a statistical test so Step One is
we just substitute
this error test
into the I sub mu
into the correctness of the inverter
right we have this we have this bound on
the TV of any test so we can sub in
error over here and we get this
statement
this is completely mechanical we just
unroll the definition of error to these
um
indicator functions
for the set
and then
oh let me remind you of uh what the
definition of g is G is the faked up
Target function uh recall so
G IS F
compose sampler for muon Z okay
so we can continue reasoning completely
mechanically let's let's take a look at
these two terms
this is the probability over random Z of
this inequality happening but by the
sampler condition
this is just X distributed according to
Mu
so is this by correctness of the sampler
this
is
our Target function G
right
so what do we do when we just collapse
these we get this which is which is way
nicer
um it says okay this is the gap
between
this function over here
H inverter inside uh versus f of x
agreeing on the example distribution mu
with the target concept versus
h
um
disagreeing with G of X over The Uniform
distribution and we have a bound on this
from the from the correctness of
learning over mu this is
this is at most sum Alpha
this
is exactly the hypothesis that we we
output
so just
rearranging things again and rewriting
according to definitions we get that the
probability when you sample a fresh x a
challenge from mu
that are
H Prime of x
is wrong
is at most
like Alpha plus Delta
right
so we sweep in the error due to the the
errors combined additively error due to
distributional inversion not being
exactly that pre-image distribution and
error from the correctness of the
original learning algorithm and we're
done
and this is like stuff like this has
shown up in a few places and it's just
it's just really nice because wherever
you want if you have one of these
conditions that's relating
um
yeah you can
you can fool correctness guarantees you
can fool in later work with with Ari we
extended this one weird trick to also
handle um a random example distribution
we can statistically simulate those
queries as well and like fool the fact
that the algorithm expects samples
distributed according to one
distribution but but not another
so
um
any questions about the one weird trick
part before we wrap up
why do you need to
in the your algorithm I guess this isn't
about the weird trick but right you were
given the the biases of each bit
explicitly you can't just like learn
this from
so because because we want to be
operating with like n many dimensions
like the the actors that goes down
quickly so like maybe we could think
about that but we we just we're
operating in the scenario where the
distribution is given to us as code
um that that would be interesting to
think about though there's connections
um like David Chao has these learning to
create versus learning to
um learning to decide
material that that I want to take a look
at here yeah thank you
couldn't just estimate these guys
okay
so yeah where do distributional
inverters come from
they they're from uniform adversary
mappings mappings that we pull out of
complexity and cryptography so at a very
high level we can go from natural proofs
to no pseudorandom functions to no
pseudorandom generators to no one-way
functions
and then from an adversary for any
one-way function uh by employatsa Luby
we can construct an algorithm for
distribute for distributional inversion
of any Target
candidate one-way function okay so this
this is sort of the positive direction
of um all of these constructions
now you might you might be saying hang
on a second
um
something doesn't add up here right
because if we if we can do this then why
don't
why do we only learn over concise
product distributions and not like I
didn't even give you ac0 samp I just
gave you specifically concise product
distributions whereas generically I said
can't I do psamp if you give me a good
enough natural property
well let's take a look at the other at
the contrapositive direction of all of
these connections
um what's that like you start with
something called distributional one-way
function
and then you add some circuitry to it
right you go backwards and you get a
one-way function that kind of runs
multiple copies with a hashing of the
distribution along my function okay then
you take this you add yet more circuitry
on top going backwards again you get a
prg by beautiful work of of Hill okay
you take this
um you do some kind of like tree
construction and now you've got a prf
and by the reverse direction of
raspberry British that means natural
proofs don't exist so this this is this
is like this is why we don't believe in
natural proofs for General circuit
classes because if we if we believe in
the very weakest primitive for
cryptography if we believe we live at
least in minicrypt there's no natural
proofs
three
how deep is that tree
um
trees linear depth
so let's let's say I start off with a
distributional one-way function or a
sampler and say ac0 or even ac0 parity
I'm you know I'm chaining together these
arrows I'm trying to build up my
adversary over here
the the pseudorandom Primitive escapes
my complexity class when I apply ggm
so I cannot generically Target an
example distribution that is samplable
in ac0 or AC zero parity this is kind of
like this this sweet spot Paradox that's
similar to
um the the reason that you can't
directly deploy CK against ac0 you you
need at least the Nissan victorson
designs in the Target complexity class
it's exactly the same problem showing up
in this in this setup so what did we do
we we wrote the inverter by hand and
plugged it into the reduction we proved
it was a distributional inverter uh
yeah because generically we incur Lin
depth overhead when we follow these
chains
and yeah that's that's pretty much oh
yeah Russell yeah so it's the
it's the ggm trade construction is that
the only problem in uh this step or do
any of the other things that well that
might take you out
yeah you can't
you can't do hashing this is zero but AC
zero month two right you could right I
think our class yeah if you wanted to
shoot for us yeah no that's that's an
excellent question because if you wanted
to show your AC zero samp other steps
also kick you out but if you want to
shoot for AC zero parody step I think
ggm is the only blocker there right like
Hill is already to go from stretch one
okay
it's so he'll give you a pseudor random
generator that gives you like a very
small stretch and then you use generic
um I think it was
maybe
um
to increase that maybe it was also in
ggm but the first part of kgm was to um
to to say oh if I even have like stretch
one I can just iterate that but that
iteration is inherently uh sequential
yeah it's a composition so that already
kicks you out already yeah so the the
tree is actually making things better
for parallelism
but um
it's linear in the input side but not in
the seed okay oh yeah yes
so depends what you want
sorry do you think you could say some
sort of like either or thing or like
either there's like a black box low
depth instruction
um
or or sorry like maybe you can get some
sort of barrier saying that if there is
no that if you were able to do a black
box
perception of a prg of a Pierre from a
flow stretch of prg then some of these
it would break
some hard to learn thing in AC zero
sample does that make sense or that
would be great and that's like something
like that is on my open problems side so
thank you for doing my open problem
slide for me and yeah I'll I'll sharpen
this up thank you it's much better to
have exactly where the obstacle is I
guess I
um got distracted by the tree
okay
so open problems get this working like
get these generics working below linear
depth and I guess the real
um the first stumbling block is already
the um the composition to increase the
stretch of the generator generically
um
maybe there's more natural
distributionally invertible example
distributions like there are things like
a gaussians that people in the world
care about that aren't the product
distribution maybe those have tiny
Samplers and distributional inverters
like you can kind of see these settings
as like parametric assumptions right
like you're saying that okay my
distribution comes from some family and
in a uniform description of that family
but maybe I can identify so you don't
have to solve the whole problem of
inferring all the parameters of the
distribution maybe you can smoothly
identify I'm facing one of these
distributions and then evoke invoke a
family a family of algorithms product
distributions are are bad because
they're not kind of robust under that
inference problem there's not that
reduction that you would hope for here
so maybe we can find a nice example
um this Rahul eye I think this goes to
your question can we can we develop
conditions under which you can't even
distributionally invert nc0 samp and
learn against that
isn't like
if you have a one-way permutation then
it's also distribution and one with
function right and we we have a swimming
factoring is hard we have one-way
permutations in nc0 so it doesn't this
does that does that go down to nc0 by
the randomized encodings
okay great then
then they totally do awesome thank you
yeah I'm I really come from complexity
Theory and finally you know can we do
like less white box access
um to this distribution the code appears
in two places in the inverter and in the
simulation of queries can we get rid of
at least one of those or get a
collection of these or something similar
oh yeah and finally it would be great if
we we could learn ac0 mod P from from
samples um but that's that's a
big open problem I think
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]
didn't have time for maybe an hour of
questions
well then maybe we'll have lunch thank
you
[Applause]
back here at 2 15.